all right it's a fairly rapid fire
question they're holding your hand
through all the different parts okay so
it begins with domain and range okay now
always the easiest way to think about
this is in terms of well a regular sine
inverse function and how its domain and
range have been squashed and stretched
in relation to that okay so really a
better way to see this is that that too
is modifying the X that three is
modifying the why it's a vertical thing
right so i would actually write it like
this okay like so and then you can you
can treat it with regards domain raise
just like any other inverse trig
function right sine inverse right its
domain is from sorry is from negative 1
so 1 right but the argument the 2x has
been changed okay so obviously we want
the exes so you just divide everything
through by two no problems ok there's my
domain I'm going to do the same thing
with range so there's four range I'm
gonna say look it's the way over three
that's going to be between big puncher
how to
so just as before i just multiply
through to get rid of all the other
constants and get away by itself now
you're like ah do you really have to
develop this and yet so yes we do
because there's a critical clue to the
rest of the paper sorry the rest of the
question right in here okay think about
it many of you at least five of you
asked me on the morning where you got to
part 4 find the area bounded by the
curve and you said which one the clue is
here can you see it well we'll get there
in a second part 2 let's grab this thing
there's being no shift it still passes
through the origin so you could draw it
just like you draw a regular sine
inverse curve they weren't too stringent
on shape I noticed but you should have
had vertical tangents at the ends once
you've got shape then you put your scale
in according to the domain and range
that you justify ok so there's 352
there's negative and there's all your
other values ok so far so good part 3
find the inverse function inverse
function now because this is going to
affect us later I will dwell on how do
you find an inverse function there are
two things you have to do and as it
happens you can actually do them in
either order it doesn't matter sometimes
it's easier to switch them around okay
you need to number one switch the input
and output write the X and the y ok
you're switching variables that's
usually the first thing that I do
wherever I cxi right way and wherever I
see why I write x the other thing you
need to do the second thing you need to
do is change the subject now as I said
you can do these in reverse order I can
change the subject first and then switch
the variables at the very end in this
case it doesn't matter all that much
does it here's what I've got there's my
function ok so I'm going to do one I'm
going to switch the variables first so I
get this exon 3 equals
sine inverse of 2y there you go that'll
be my inverse function I've switched
them around but I need to tidy this
thing up ok so I'm going to change the
subject I want the subject to Y so which
lies your besides fix a website that
gives you two wire net of course all you
have to do is divide through and why is
there there you go there's the inverse
ok so you can see I did switch variables
here and now I've made it the subject no
problem ok now I'm part 4 they ask you
for an area right they say find the area
bounded by the curve whichever one is
the x axis is the x axis x equals
negative half and x equals 0 now when
you ask me this I said you need to make
a judgment ok and you just see this will
happen as well ok what do you think
would make the most sense don't forget
it's two marks right it's sort of
flowing on everything is flowing on ok
which curve am I probably going to be
working out the area of and the answer
is it's the original have a look at it
the boundary they gave us was nebula
half there it is right there it's a nice
neat value ok if I had a grafter this
hey what would this look like to quickly
there you go over there and over there
because this is sine X on three that's
going to be minus PI on three there
which is something like 1.0 for 1.5 or
something like that ok so therefore
negative a half which is the boundary
their tools is some awkward spot in here
so you get this weirdo looking area ok
no nothing they could ask you that area
but it seems unusual given the way they
have led us through this ok especially
being that we've got the graph of this
and not the graph of this ok so there's
your first problem is judging that ok
even so it's not a hard area to get its
this area
okay so you can see some of you because
you know how to integrate inverse trig
functions would have said okay I'll form
an integral with this guy right and you
can do that that's fine but being that
you've already worked out what the
inverse is it makes more sense to work
out what this rectangle is okay and then
do it by subtraction okay the reason why
it's we're useful is because the area
you must subtract has already been
worked out for you there it is right
there okay so how would you do it this
is the way I wrote it up I said the area
is equal to all right the rectangle
first wat its dimensions it's a half
right there and three pile to that way
okay so there's my rectangle their
problems okay now i'm going to subtract
an area and I know it's subtraction I'm
trying to make it smaller than the
rectangle so here is one of the cases
where I'm validated I'm justified in
saying absolute value okay because
whatever comes out to this I want it to
be positive okay so what should the
integral be where is your fault now be
careful because I'm now thinking about
this guy the inverse function right I've
swapped X's and Y's okay so therefore
here when I think about the boundaries I
need to swap X's and Y's okay the X that
this is talking about is this value
right you see how they've switched
around so this is going to be from
negative 3 player to all the way up to
zero okay alternatively if you had drawn
a whole new graph for this guy right
well yeah then you've got the left hand
side you can twist your header you can
see see it going in that direction okay
so from there to there on this we had
respect to X absolute value okay and the
rest is sort of just mechanical okay we
can't do it though good play we might be
able to skip a few steps because we can
see where this is going to go 3 PI on
formal this half is going to come out
right you're going to get sine X on
three okay so that's going to be
see three cars exon 3 right and not only
that I also have this this whole thing
is an odd function isn't it so rather
than think about this guy which is an
awkward value i'm going to go from
nought to 3.2 because i'm taking the
absolute value of the whole lot ok
that's a whole series of changes but
hopefully you can see what i'm about to
do okay i'm gonna write it like Sir 5035
on to okay there you go taking out the
constant switch this around concern on
function i'm taking the absolute value
and now i will integrate absolute value
there's going to be the three up front
there you go do i check out doesn't
follow I'm pretty sure that's okay
because when you differentiate that your
third will get rid of the three no
problems okay now we can quickly
evaluate this this is not hard to do
because it's x over 3 right this is just
going to become pale too what's caused a
plan to Caza plan to is 0 cos of 0 is 1
right see you're going to get 3 PI on 4
minus the absolute value of negative 3
on 2 matrix just negative 2 I think okay
there's a there's a 0-1 in there which
is what makes that negative doesn't
matter because there's an absolute value
sign and I guess we can just tidy up
what would you take out I take out three
quarters i think they go and that's in
units square right now that was worth
that was no phones out to marks too much
okay so i would expect the two marks to
be here in this integration and here in
this evaluation and simplifying okay of
all of this they were leading you in
this direction right getting the inverse
function so that this step would be
really easy to do okay